stalemate is just one of the possible
ways to end the game and a tie another
way is to simply agree to a draw this
might happen if neither player can see a
way to victory one person offers the
draw and the other can accept or decline
another way to get a draw is if the
exact same position is repeated three
times after three repetitions either
player can claim a draw when it is their
turn to move or if you're playing online
a draw will automatically be called
after five repetitions another way to
draw is if neither player has enough
pieces to checkmate like loan king vs.
loan King you'll learn more about this
later finally you can also draw if 50
pairs of moves have been played on the
board without any captures or pawn moves
this keeps you from dying of boredom as
you and your opponent move your looks
back and forth forever now it's your
turn to practice drawn positions